best-selling author and social
researcher her name is Brittany Brown
she burst into public consciousness with
her TED talk in 2010 the power of
vulnerability remains the site's fourth
most popular talk listen to this it has
36 million views Wow today Brene brown
is busy juggling consulting and speaking
events at fortune 500 companies
including IBM Disney and Google her new
book focuses on how each of us can
cultivate effective leadership it's
called dare to leave brave work tough
conversations whole hearts Rene Brown
joins us once again first on CBS morning
to talk about her latest book it's
always good to have you at the table
brené Brown good morning it is it isn't
a masterpiece just the fact that you've
had 36 million views he says to me that
people are very open to finding out more
about this but I know very few bosses
and leaders that think it's okay to show
vulnerability but you say you can't be
you can't have courage without
vulnerability what do you mean you know
it was interesting because I used to
spend a lot of time led go into these
companies kind of evangelizing about
vulnerability it's important then one
day I found myself on a military base
talking to Special Forces and I just
asked a simple question give me an
example of courage that you've seen or
witnessed in your life or that you know
you've done yourself that didn't require
uncertainty risk and emotional exposure
which is the definition of vulnerability
give me a single example of courage that
did not require that and there was just
silence until one guy just raised his
hand and said three tours ma'am there is
no courage without vulnerability and so
now I just ask audiences that simple
question give me an example of courage
that doesn't require uncertainty risk
and emotional exposure you say most
people think of courage as a personality
trait not a skill you say it's a skill
it's a skill set I mean we've been
studying it for I've been doing this
work for 20 years the last seven years
really looking at courage and leadership
specifically for skillsets
can you rumble with vulnerability can
you stay in tough things when they get
uncomfortable and awkward or do you tap
out gieux and this is a hard one living
into your values are you clear about
what your values are and have you
operationalize those in
behaviors do you know what behaviors
support your values what don't three
breathing trusts can you build trust and
be trustworthy and the last one which I
think was really interesting was
learning how to get back up learning how
to rise because we found that people are
more willing to be courageous upfront if
they know how to rise yeah I mean that's
why I'm sorry John that's what I called
this a masterpiece because to just sum
up everything and then you write courage
is contagious to scale daring leadership
and build courage in teams and
organizations we have to cultivate a
culture in which brave work tough
conversations whole hearts the
expectation in armor is not unnecessary
or rewarded that's the thing because
people want to know how do we scale this
type of behavior yeah
courage is incredibly contagious as is
fear as we can see in the world as is
scarcity and so courage is contagious
and we can teach it we can learn it we
can measure it and we have to create
cultures we're being armored all the
time is not rewarded behavior so first
of all as a disciple of the gifts of
imperfect parenting I have now let's
move on and I don't I hate to get a
political but one of the best leaders we
have right now who has totally reformed
a political party in His image who's
gotten two people on the Supreme Court
and and achieved other things so thinks
showing vulnerability is the key to loss
not showing vulnerability is in fact one
of his signature traits so that seems to
be the opposite of what you're saying
yeah and I think so that's why I'm glad
we went there because here's the thing
John goes there yeah John goes hey I'll
go with you John you can absolutely get
away I mean you can you can get masses
of people behind you if you do two
things
if you weaponize uncertainty if you take
people who are in uncertainty and and
guarantee them certainty and then give
people someone to blame for their pain
mm-hmm I mean you can you can do
anything you want yeah the problem with
that is that fear has a short shelf life
and you cannot do that for very long
the question is always what kind of
damage are you gonna do while you're
able to do that but I do not I have seen
no evidence and I'm reading Doris Kearns
Goodwin right now so she's leadership I
don't think that's sustainable let me
ask you this I'm a leader in whatever
I'm doing in my life how do I be more
vulnerable if I want to try and access
this trait that is so important so
vulnerability is not disclosure so let's
like that's the big mythology right it's
not like I know a lot of leaders who
show up and just everything that has
nothing to do with courage or
vulnerability vulnerability is can you
manage uncertainty and risk an emotional
exposure can you stay in the hard
conversation can you tell the truth can
you give feedback when it's hard can you
ask for feedback when it's hard
bonor ability is I believe and it's
probably 60% of the book the only path
to courage and it is the birthplace of
innovation creativity trust empathy I
love it when people call and say hey can
you come talk to our company Brene we'd
love to have you speak just don't
mention like vulnerability you hope that
people that read this book it will
result in one behavior change for
leaders that they should read it
cover-to-cover on a flight one behavior
change that you think all leaders need
is what it's gonna be simple clear is
kind unclear is unkind stop stop
avoiding the tough conversations because
you think you're being polite are kinds
of people that's not kind right they're
great everything you say it's so you're
Renee brown thank you so much thank you
all very nice